mais tu dis que ta voix ne te donne pas
de plaisir parce que tu forces tout le
temps quand tu fais des playbacks à la
télé tu es tranquille au moins oui
chaud devant mon lapin bébé chanteur et
grand asséminateur voici Alain champfort
du tronche en forcloc en forgensbourg et
champforce en fort tout ce qu'il y a de
plus d'endu le frenchy ferry raconte sa
vie de ma femme alors Alain Chamfort
bonsoir c'est même pas ton vrai nom
Alain Chamfort en fait Alain Le Govic
mais rassure-toi oui toute façon le vrai
champ fort j'ai vérifié ça plaît pas je
suis en forme non plus ah tiens donc il
s'appelait rock oui effectivement
[Musique]
tu as commencé comment tu viens de quel
milieu toi un milieu tout à fait simple
normal
disons que dès les débuts des années 60
et l'arrivée de salut les copains je
crois que c'est ça a beaucoup contribué
ça au changement de
mes intérêts quoi j'ai été attiré par
la musique parler puis de tout ce que la
musique véhicule a une façon de se
comporter la mode enfin toutes ces
choses le regard sur les filles enfin
j'ai commencé à m'intéresser à tout ça
grâce à la musique elle a commencé à 15
ans avec des groupes qui s'appelaient
comment les dreamers
et puis après tu as fait du riz au même
blues aussi à un moment et après on a
monté un groupe qui s'appelait les mods
c'était les beaux-arts qui les ai
c'était jamais bien c'est ça j'adore
cette vidéo
après j'ai travaillé
après voilà c'est à dire que les modes
nous ont permis de décrocher un contrat
enregistrement dans la maison de disque
vogue et Dutronc était en train de faire
son premier disque et comme on
fréquentait le même café à côté le même
studio etc on a et nous a proposé de
l'accompagner est-ce que lui vivait
assez mal la promotion finalement il est
préférée avec une bande de copains que
de se retrouver tout seul sauf qu'il t'a
viré pour une affaire de Pépé quand même
bon il y a eu des il y avait un peu de
dolites comme ça entre nous sur des
détails stupides mais on avait l'âge
aussi que des rivalités
et alors un jour tu as eu le trou noir
quand tu as quitté du tronc je prends 72
et un jour vin buggy t'a présenté à
Claude François qu'à l'époque dirigée de
flèches et qui voulait faire de flèches
la timela française c'est ça et toi au
départ tu veux écrire pour lui en fait
oui c'est pour ça que ça veut dire que
je suis venu avec un ami à moi qui
s'appelle qui s'appelle Michel Pollet
avec qui on écrivait les premières
chansons et Claude a réagi favorablement
sur ce qu'on faisait
et il nous a donné les moyens de se dire
une pièce un studio avec tout le
matériel dont on souhaitait
toute la technologie de l'époque donc la
gueule que tu as tu ferais mieux de
faire des disques que je mettrai tes
posters dans podium mais il voulait
qu'on fasse un disque ensemble à la
limite est-ce que c'était c'était notre
travail en commun qui l'appréciait et il
voulait qu'on proposait de chanter
nous-mêmes des chansons parce que comme
on n'avait jamais réussi à faire un
succès il nous est pas totalement
confiance quand même parce que lui il
avait confiance quand les choses étaient
établies donc
chanter en duo avec quelqu'un d'autre
c'était sa venait vraiment ridicule
de mecs alors il y a eu l'amour en
France et le bébé chanteur et toi tu
étais assez fasciné par Claude François
par sa réussite par sa puissance et puis
quand tu gambergé tu te disais c'est nul
quand même tout ça non ce qui s'est
passé nul je disais que c'était tu
voulais pas c'était
bon en disant que je me sentais pas
complètement en phase quoi il y avait
des
il y avait des appartenances à ce monde
là ce que j'avais envieais et que
c'était gai connaître le succès d'avoir
accès à toutes ces choses que ça que le
succès permet mais en même temps j'avais
pas envie d'être prisonnier de ça enfin
je voulais je trouvais que c'était
normal de chercher à évoluer même au
milieu de ça et j'avais pas envie de
m'en sortir mais j'ai envie de continuer
à évoluer normalement quoi c'était
l'époque où j'ai lu une interview de toi
très marrante où tu disais voilà
l'époque certains soirs je buvais deux
trois whisky comme ça pour me désinhiber
quand je chantais et j'étais tellement
désinhibé que j'étais un peu bourré et
il y avait des par terre entiers de
minettes consentantes et c'était mon
époque chanteur inséminateur
et tu disais comme Herbert Léonard
d'ailleurs oui le cité parce que c'était
arrêté ce mot là m'est venu parce que
avec Marc on s'était amusé comme ça à
trouver des finitions on avait trouvé
chanteur gynécologue pour Charles Dumont
quelque chose comme ça alors tu as eu le
même problème enfin avec c'est un peu
quand les filles ont commencé à crier
Alain Alain ben vous êtes séparés parce
que lui il était jaloux quoi quand même
Jean Claude François
jaloux je sais pas enfin disons que ça
ça les années un petit peu il était très
heureux d'avoir trouvé qu'il était un
producteur à succès parce que il le
pouvait en faisant en sortant mes
disques et de l'autre côté il était il
donnait naissance à un confrère enfin un
confrère qui devenait aussi un
concurrent donc ça dépendait des moments
et des moments il était très heureux que
je sois là des moments finalement ton
physique t'as pas aidé contrairement à
ce qu'on pourrait croire
je sais pas j'ai au début certainement
que c'est parce que c'est il a il a eu
envie de me faire enregistrer surtout
par rapport à la gueule que j'avais à
17h15 ans tu es pas des problèmes avec
les [ __ ] toi non si ça peut être
terrible non
c'était difficile à vivre ouais c'est à
dire que sur harceler mais ça va arriver
d'avoir des quelques problèmes comme ça
enfin surtout à ce moment-là et après je
les ai vécu plus normalement mais quand
j'avais 15 ans c'est vrai que ça
m'agressait il m'est arrivé de deux
trois histoires comme ça que j'ai qu'ils
sont un peu mal passés je me sentais
plusieurs trouver dans les situations
impossibles
impossible c'est sûr que beaucoup de
gens doivent vivre
qui était nouvelle pour moi alors après
bon tu as travaillé Gainsbourg alors là
il y a pas de problème il était pas
jaloux il disait un mec comme champfort
il tombe toutes les filles qui veulent
lui dès le départ il avait pris il avait
pris son parti quoi
c'est un peu gratuit j'ai jamais été en
plus démonstratif à ce sujet là enfin je
veux dire au contraire j'ai toujours
essayé de garder ma vie privée ou enfin
via tout ce qui pouvait m'amener hors de
propos professionnels j'ai été très
discret donc alors vous avez fait
ensemble rock n' roll qui a pas eu un
grand succès pas de succès du tout
un tube quoi un gros succès de 45 jours
et l'album sur lequel il était
il y avait quand même bien toi titres
n'a pas marché du tout
c'est mal terminé
une tournée de promotion infernale sur
toutes les chaînes j'imagine non je suis
pas sûr ah bon
mais tu dis que ta voix ne te donne pas
de plaisir parce que tu forces tout le
temps quand tu fais des playbacks à la
télé tu es tranquille au moins oui mais
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu